providence rhode island home to seven
colleges and a thriving art scene
this renaissance city is a constant
beehive of activity
in 2005 abby and her best friend rico
bought a restaurant called down city
smack in the center of town rico and i
were on the beach one day
and i told him that i was interested in
buying down city and he said i want to
own a restaurant too
i was spending a lot of money in
restaurants eating and drinking and i
figured why not give myself the money
instead
make it a double he has a full-time day
job and my job is to take care of
everything in this restaurant you start
with all the specials i'm gonna get the
wine okay well i've been in the
restaurant business for 33 years so the
decisions i make i really don't consult
recounting about them i just do them and
this would go perfectly with the pork
special i am the checkpoint behind down
city and i was putting 100 of my faith
in abby
but at this point it's not going well
i need more asses in the seasons
i think it's a beautiful restaurant i
think our menu is creative and the food
is good i don't know what's wrong it's
all [ __ ] up abby has her blindfolds on
because she doesn't want to admit that
she's part of the problem just give him
no let me do it abby acts like whatever
don't argue corella deville
i just wanted to answer when i called
something out abby is a complete psycho
[ __ ] [ __ ] i just want an answer
which is a recipe for utter disaster i
had fixed it yesterday i checked it
before i left it's like really [ __ ]
happening i'm not yelling i'm talking
they think that this is a democracy and
it's not if you cannot follow my rules
then get the [ __ ] out as long as you
work for me you do it my way and upset
it's basically abby's way of the highway
and it's definitely why your
restaurant's failing welcome to my
nightmare
there's no consistency it's just
like mushrooms if people are complaining
about the food maybe there's something
wrong with the food it is impossible for
the prize to be ice cold maybe just abby
saying it's great does not make it great
that's how the plate is prepared do you
not like it no no she built this 50 item
menu that is just horrible they hate the
chicken pie yards what nobody can say
anything about the menu because it's her
menu she takes it personally maybe
they're not the right decisions but
they're my decisions
i have to get abby on board to
move forward because
my life is at stake here
all i think about is why people are not
coming to my restaurant if something
happened here where i had to declare
bankruptcy
it could
very strongly affect my day job that's
stress we've got all these bills to pay
this weekend that's the spec
this week
i've called upon chef ramsay because of
his honesty and bluntness
but he's gonna have his work cut out for
him
i guarantee
[Music]
hello chef ramsay how are you welcome to
down city nice to meet you hi it's my
pleasure and your first name is abby
abby good to see you and you're the
owner i'm the owner general manager
everything yeah my business partner
isn't here he'll come in tonight okay
great yep his name is rico right so
you're trained classically in terms of
absolutely not you would not want me to
cook you anything already
and on a scale of one to ten mark the
food what would you say where are we
it's a chat wow
wow wow yeah perfect i'm starving
because the room service next door was
shocking
wait a minute wait the room service next
door was shocking
what do you mean it was shocking
there's a little hotel next to the beach
hotel we do the real service for that
hotel what was the problem
honestly yeah that was embarrassing
why what did you have this pissy grainy
suit that was stone cold hold on it gets
worse crab cakes that were stone cold in
the center it was just like this ball of
mush
disgusting
disgusting disgusting
whoa i was like oh damn he went there he
just really went there that's impossible
that's impossible of a crappy stone cold
you're telling me i'm exaggerating
i think you're one of those customers
that i would fire immediately
yeah you fire customers
i have okay
well let me sit down and eat can i
suggest something i don't want to miss
anything because if you're now telling
me that that room service was you at
your best i'm [ __ ] myself before i
start eating let me tell you that wow
wow
i don't know what he's talking about
blah blah blah blah blah
where would you like me to sit i'm gonna
go right back here excellent describe
the food for me um comfort food middle
of the road middle of the road
when was the last time somebody sent
food back today oh today oh you did wow
well well i'm sorry
okay um i'll look through the menu is
this this i suggest something or no you
don't want my suggestion if you're gonna
talk to me honestly fine if you're gonna
start you know going defensive i'm not
gonna get defensive i'm just defending
what we do here
now abby i'm not here to argue
you asked me to come here and look at
this place to help you out let's get one
thing clear straight away cut the
[ __ ] okay if you're gonna sit there
and start bullshitting i'm not sitting
i'm stealing i'm gonna go for your balls
big time wow when you just told me five
minutes ago the food's 10 out of 10. the
room surface is perfect basically i'm
going to eat and i'm going to leave
unless you start telling me the truth i
i don't know where you're coming from i
really don't know where you're going
i absolutely think you're [ __ ] full
of [ __ ] i've been here five minutes
and already you're in denial i'm not in
denial i will back up anything my
kitchen does fine i'm open-minded can i
order the food absolutely thank you so
much go for it appreciate it
wow what a welcoming yeah welcome to
providence another did female cage
fighters holy crap
boy i can't wait to rico gets here
hi how are you i'm brother how are you
good good good and this is josh chuck
specifically gary welcome to the dollar
tree nice so nice to see that friendly
face
thank you
um is the owner abby or is that
defensive yeah
it's scaring me
okay appetizers calamari yeah crispy
rings with hot sweet pepper sauce yeah
i'll go for some okay you don't smell
peppers like that either
no i guess you don't i didn't even know
it said haven't been here three years
three years
okay uh three-way nachos it says it's a
party in my mouth
yeah
well if it's good enough to be put on
the menu i'm going to try it so i'll go
for party in your mouth okay
and the um award-winning meatloaf that's
our claim to fame ready
thanks josh you're welcome
please may god
we don't die in rhode island okay this
is gordon ramsay's order
let's make orders food i'm a good cook
but uh that is not my menu of course i
want to do well but i'm not sure what
chef ramsay's gonna think he's like is
this how you spell peppers in america
three feet because it's b-e-p-b yeah
there's three p's in there never mind
[Music]
hi how are you how are you oh thank you
good to see you jason gordon good to see
you so you're
waiting the waiter yes dining room
manager yes brilliant and being the head
waiter how would you describe the food
here
below par yeah abby said it was a 10.
so i'm in for a treat oh yeah
carl meyer okay
well this is the crispy calamari palomar
yes
and um why is it looking so wet uh it's
a sauce that they toss it in just so
that again you fry it they fry it and
then you and they toss it in the sauce
and it's soaking wet all the crispy
batter is just coming off you know it's
not everybody's cup of tea it's not mine
no certainly it's not mine either but
however i'm optimistic
what do you think
um
[Music]
i mean look at that there
oh my god i'm done on that one yeah i'll
get ready
thank you you're welcome
wow
soggy chewy disgusting calamari shocking
what do you say about it you spit the
calamari back up
that's hysterical what was he bitching
about
spit it out i'm gonna like go at his
throat today
and this is a party in your mouth
this is the party in my mouth it should
be top plate very hot it looks dreadful
i think i've just thrown up in my mouth
what a mess
oh boy
i'm taking it that was one party you
didn't want to attend it wasn't a party
in my mouth it was like a funeral in my
mouth a feeler yeah well it kind of does
look like something died
what's mad with that that's gross what
we're not doing too good here i was
ready to light
choke him
maybe this is the one thing i like he
doesn't like anything maybe this will be
the one what the meanwhile oh maybe this
will be it
wow that's the music
and this is the award-winning the
award-winning meme yeah i'm excited
thank you you're welcome
it doesn't move on there does it
[Music]
wow
that's disgusting
what do we think wow
it's not even hot
i'm sorry it's sort of lukewarm
solidified chunks of crap
that's pretty much
the norm
it must be freaking embarrassing if you
deserve this it is embarrassing i don't
like the meatloaf here at all we set
ourselves up for disappointment when we
put award-winning in front of it what
was the problem with me it's disgusting
can you be more specific i didn't i
didn't hear what he said i'm gonna have
to ask him abby and chef ramsay are
going to go to blows can i have a word
of the team
it's inevitable it's going to happen so
the food was shocking hello disgusting
dated [ __ ]
so
who is the hf here
we don't really have one but i guess you
don't have a head chef but i guess i'm
the closest thing close what does that
mean
talk to me abby
that means that i fired my other chef
and he took over and i didn't want to
give him a title until he proved to
himself that he could handle the kitchen
abby what you're employing is a ship
with no captain at the helm and the team
desperate for guidance
no guidance there's no standards no
standards there's no consistency
so
who came up with the menu if this is
america comfort food somebody's dreaming
here
i did
i did i take full responsibility for the
menu you have no cooking background but
you put the menu together
abby you've got to understand how
frustrating this is it's ridiculous i
don't know what to say fix it you fix it
that's right come on abby how can i fix
it when you stand there in front of your
team rating you and your restaurant and
your food 10 out of 10.
dreamer i don't i don't think it's as
bad as you say it can stop being in
denial
can you be more specific about meatloaf
what did you not like about the meatloaf
oh
[ __ ]
can you say something besides just loopy
i've been called worse than that wake up
and admit it [ __ ]
bring it on oh come on bring it on
what you mean bring it on
perhaps chef ramsay say everything
you've done everything that you dreamed
of doing is [ __ ] i was blown away i need
some fresh air
[Music]
after chef ramsay's harsh critique the
food was shocking dated and tasteless
abby has a conversation with the one
person she believes is always right
herself
so what do i do like just get out of the
restaurant business then obviously my 33
years in the business is like worthless
and i have no idea what the [ __ ] i'm
doing
okay
i think i'm gonna open up that hot dog
stand down the beach
want some tea or something no
i believe from the bottom of my heart
that
he's he's wrong
i really don't care what he says
he's completely full of [ __ ] like
seriously our meatloaf is like what put
us on the map
i mean it's great
[Music]
i don't like the meatloaf
you really don't i honestly don't we had
it the other night together
what what what didn't you like about it
i think our food is mediocre like it's
not minnie me seriously you're telling
me now you don't like it we eat it
because we're here yeah this is not my
restaurant or choice i will not dine
here in my off time you're saying for
what we serve comfort food meatloaf
pasta steak whatever you're saying for
those are even for that no no so now
you're all telling me that you don't
like the menu
i feel stabbed in the back i guess
you're just hitting me with this now do
you know what we're up against if we
even opened our mouth about the menu
once every time we opened our mouth [ __ ]
off [ __ ] you you don't know anything
we're all at a point now where we're
just like this is what she wants let's
just serve it out we'll take it out of
the window and bring it to the table
what are we gonna have an opinion about
now oh you're so full of [ __ ] no no no
no no [ __ ] talk to us no
without a doubt she's in denial
[Music]
it's an hour before dinner service and
down city's other owner rico shows up
hello unaware of what happened earlier
but that's quickly about to change
i don't even know how to answer that
one of those seats
i think it's time for abby to find out
that the outbursts and treating
employees badly i think it's definitely
time she has someone other than myself
telling her you can't be doing this
[Music]
how are you
good to see you nice to meet you i'm
wake up rico now have you got two
minutes sure we're gonna catch up uh
where should we go let's go
he may rip me apart too but i just want
this restaurant to work so let's get
turning it around uh what a day um
obviously you weren't here for lunch
just explain what you do during the day
um i work for credit union during the
day i do their mortgages for them okay
wow finance yes finance and then you
bought a ration and i bought a
restaurant
how's that worked out for you so far oh
horribly if we had to close this
tomorrow what are you in for
nine
[ __ ] ready
this is quite serious [ __ ] now oh yeah
what happens if it fails i could
possibly who was my day job really
because i'm in the financial field i'm
advising people on what to do with their
mortgaging and financing their
properties and things like that so
you're up to there
you've got a big stake in this
restaurant and a huge amount of jeopardy
if it fails mm-hmm you're right
there's a line that i walk in here a
very fine line i have a lot of penn
state but i totally let abby run the
restaurant and maybe that's a mistake on
my phone
with dinner service already underway
what about something you drink to get
you started chef ramsay is eager to
spend some time in the kitchen to see
how it functions wow tight behind the
line
so who's doing one explain the line to
me
station and then we have our shower down
there jesus why is the place so messy
[Music]
is the kitchen normally this filthy
last couple days it's been uh a lot
going on
that is foul with the kitchen in
disarray chef ramsay goes on the hunt to
find out what is lurking below
[Music]
oh my god
hi this is gross down here holy crap
look at that lamb bones just dumped in
there like that
what is that
chicken carcasses oh my god and while
chef ramsay has his hands full in the
walk-in god knows what that's abby has
her hands full in the dining room
abby
i need a new calamari with the sauce on
the side because it says it's too mushy
can i have another calamari with sauce
on the side please
is it yeah let me take it out of the way
for you i need a spin dip this is cold
i'm going out of my mind right now it's
a nightmare can we just 86 fifth special
every single one of them has been sent
back uh richard abby i need one minute
just both together one minute why is
right now like are you kidding me
have a look in there look at the state
of what they're cooking out of
have any idea what's in what box uh what
goes where
over here
now you've got a little bag of uh
chicken carcasses on this one here
you've got some raw chicken cooked pork
there
this is you with 30 years in the
business yeah hold on it gets worse
i don't know what that is well
look at the cheese or something but what
is that there what is that what you lots
of words the place is a filthy mess look
what is that lamb bones
and who's organizing this you haven't
got a head chef jimmy is my head chef so
we have a head chef
before you weren't ready
to confirm he was a head chef all of a
sudden we discovered mess down here now
he's appointed
why don't we just sell a place and just
get out of this business
it's like i was talking to rico has
nothing to do with you have nothing to
do with me no
excuse me what do you think i'm doing i
mean i'm i'm chilling you're being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] this wasn't like this
wasn't like this
you're calling me a [ __ ] [ __ ] i am
you stuck up precious little [ __ ] let
me tell you something boy here we go
listen to me i'm not going to listen to
you you're in denial
yes you are and you can't even accept it
you'll walk out again
there you go click the bird
that's your attitude and that's your
partner i'm really sorry but this wasn't
like this before i got here she just
deluded that woman you are insane you
weren't like blame me all you want these
excuses that you're insane i'm just
saying you're insane you're [ __ ]
insane that refrigerator was not like
that before you got here you're in
denial
flip out again i will never allow that
refrigerator on those boats and the
moldy lamb bones i don't even talk to my
stuff like this
are you still here not now guys please
please please [ __ ] him
[Music]
right from the beginning chef ramsay and
abby have clashed
in denial i don't think it's as bad as
you say
dreamer but after a confrontation over
the state of the walk-in you're being a
[ __ ] [ __ ] this wasn't like this
you're calling me a [ __ ] [ __ ]
abby has completely lost it you are
insane you weren't like blame me all you
want these excuses that you're insane
i've been saying you're insane and while
she has had enough for chef ramsay
you are so in denial you need therapy he
has had enough of her
you're a disgrace in the industry you'll
get out of my restaurant
are you still here not now guys please
please [ __ ] him
[Music]
chef ramsey
[Music]
hey guys i need some privacy please
this is uh
too serious i'm not gonna jeopardize 25
years busting my ass off in this
industry to take that from someone so
in denial
i really don't need this i would rather
if this restaurant closed than have him
in here
that refrigeration unit was a mess
behind the line was a mess i'm really
sorry honestly she's got to start
listening i i know i and i don't know
how to make her do i really
i don't know
is he he's coming back tonight isn't he
i don't give a [ __ ] where he goes you
can go to hell for a like here
[Music]
if you want me to leave i'm out of here
absolutely not
absolutely not
okay i need
your help i've got my 100 support
100
okay i'm gonna go for a walk and i'll
come back okay thank you thank you
abby needs to be on board with us and
stop her denial of everything we have to
break through it
i feel pretty shitty
how would you feel if someone is telling
you that your life's work and everything
you dreamed of doing for your whole life
is [ __ ]
now i'm completely questioning myself
and i hope we can have a conversation
about what needs to be done in this
restaurant
[Music]
after a volatile evening that included a
massive blow-up with chef ramsay and a
weak dinner service abby has been
clearly humbled and seems ready to
finally listen to what chef ramsay has
to say
okay let's agree on something today's
been a [ __ ] day
absolutely i'm not here to rub your face
in it let's get that right okay but abby
you know i've had failure in my life
but one thing i'm not in is denial and
when i do make a mistake i admit it
timestamped
so tomorrow we need to start being
honest and open so i can start
rebuilding i can't rebuild on bs i agree
i want you to be here i want you to help
me get this restaurant to where i
need it to
and
be
we know it can be
yeah
tomorrow we start again get some rest
[Music]
it's a new day and abby and rico are on
board for change morning morning morning
but before that can happen chef ramsay
wants to give the staff something they
have been rarely given a chance to talk
freely without getting fired
so that's what we're gonna do
i want each of you
to write down
some questions
and direct them to the person
you want
and to answer
this is gonna be another hell day for me
don't sign your name it's anonymous i
knew that if we were gonna do an
exercise
um and talking about the restaurant i
knew that it was all gonna be directed
at me thank you very much
okay good
here's the uh the first one
wow
abby
wine is the menu it's so huge
we uh just um to give the customer more
choices but the amount of dishes is
absurd
and the more dishes
the lower the standard
hey abby and jimmy the quality of the
food needs to improve how can we fix it
good question it and it all comes down
to menu size with as many items that
there are if you prep
50 items just for dinner alone and then
the dessert menu if you can't prep
enough stuff yeah it's like you you just
can't do it who's putting all those
dishes on there oh yeah happy
when i put this menu together i just
expected my staff to just do this menu
abby why do not allow
anyone to express their opinions without
it being seen as a personal attack to
you
since i bought this restaurant i became
a defensive
[ __ ] i question and i get upset of the
fact that you're questioning what i'm
doing that's paranoia
we do care about this restaurant you are
our friends so
we want to see you succeed and the
answer i've gotten from you in the past
is
[ __ ] you that's not true we're just here
for money or we're just here because
we're just here because we can't get
other jobs and stuff and it's it's
hurtful because when you invest so much
time and you we would do anything for
you and i completely realized we've just
got to talk more instead of yelling and
screaming can't just be my show it's not
the abbey show it's the down city show
are you ready to embrace change
yeah absolutely major change absolutely
i think this experience is making abby
realize that she has to relinquish
control and i think she's going to do it
because i think abby turning around is
definitely paramount for this restaurant
to survive
all right jimmy let's come on as abby's
menu was clearly bogging down the
kitchen chef ramsay has gone through it
and scaled it back tonight i'm just
going to keep it really simple for
tonight's dinner service half the items
are off the menu and he's introducing a
roasted chicken special just take the
breast fat side down just cut through
everyone's excited and we can't have
another night like the previous few it's
time to get it right happy happy makes
it a lot more simple big time
folks good evening welcome to down city
holiday
did you guys decide on appetizers we're
gonna have an order of the calamari so
we're doing two calamaris uh let's get
the grilled chicken breast please
chicken breasts
i've got to get everyone involved if we
are going to take down city to the next
step to the next level
all right here we go order fire
calamari posse salad he swash salad
make sure everything comes up at the
same time tonight's smaller menu is
having an immediate impact wipe the
plates please better prepared appetizers
are quickly leaving the kitchen that's
37 that's up these um appetizers are
going to 39. can you help her run and
when you combine that with a common
under control abby at the helm can you
run this to next table please down
city's dinner service is off to a good
start
calamari another frise salad no egg
jimmy we've got to bang all these uh
entrees out
here you're on apps you're on table 28.
now i'm confused on where we are for
apps you need table 28. i don't even
have a 36 up here i don't know i didn't
say 36. one two
three come on guys there's nothing
coming out
jimmy was supposed to be the leader in
the kitchen calling out chickens give me
a favor get two of these oh you're doing
something
and they just started crossing paths no
one seemed to know what the hell they
were doing back there 29 and 39 yes or
no no i'm still waiting on 2018 oh
[ __ ] worms
it's an hour and a half into a dinner
service that started out as promising
can i have some food up in the window
please no dude dude this cruise boost is
runny and gross but unfortunately has
declined rapidly they're not even here
that's all the way down there they have
none of this and not surprisingly diners
are losing their patience
it's not here within the next five
minutes
can i get something up on the line
please yeah right now right now jimmy's
doing all three sections he's covering
the grill he's covering the salmon he's
covering the chicken he's trying to run
the kitchen at the same time he's got
nothing behind him oh my god what a [ __ ]
show
well we've been here since 6 30 and it's
already 25 of them so
i've got people that had put their
orders in an hour and 15 hour and a half
some of them where the [ __ ] was that
food let's uh find our server and let's
just go did that be fire chicken gum
give it to him i need it right now
please come on is it your first time at
the rodeo wait um guys i've got food
dying in the window chris please
yeah i can't take this it was a disgrace
it was horrifying it was embarrassing
don't make this they just walk
oh my god
we need a home we need to just happen
jimmy doesn't have any excuses anymore
his excuse for months has been our menu
is too big so we give him a smaller menu
to do and they still can't turn it out
so i mean where do we go from here i
need one chicken up in the line right
now with abby pushing her kitchen staff
i'm not taking this out until it's all
up on the line can i have a chicken on
the line in my hand okay they still
struggle thank you but managed to get
the last entrees out there we go and
that's that's everything start cleaning
up
good night thank you thank you
now an unusually calm abby jimmy come
out here listen to me is about to let
loose what i saw tonight was
the worst [ __ ] show i've ever seen ever
ever ever seen no i know i know i know
it did not go smoothly but they they
they say
jimmy we were an hour in before
more than two dinners went out
an hour into service i'm almost
accepting that none of us know what the
[ __ ] we're doing and we can't get to the
next step i'm actually considering that
after tonight i don't know if i have the
staff to get it back i don't know if we
can do it tonight's dinner service was
plagued by confusion and incompetence in
the kitchen can i get something up on
the line please i'm confused on where we
are come on is it your first time at the
rodeo well you know the problems are
obvious to chef ramsay but it's time to
find out if abby is still in denial
abby what do you see tonight what
happened is it happens all the time as
soon as the line gets hit with a number
of slips at one time the kitchen folds
it goes down in flames and um
i've lost confidence in my kitchen um
honestly
[Music]
jimmy
i'm not blaming you entirely i'm looking
at the tools you've got to work with and
it's a disaster behind that line there's
no way on earth this group of cooks can
pull off
a new menu
so seeing how frustrating it's been here
i made a call
to a very experienced chef in my team to
be here
first thing tomorrow morning getting
your crew at a respectable level it's
cool having his chat to help us all out
and it's going to be a good experience
for all of us
tomorrow's come back day we're
relaunching with a new menu let's roll
up our sleeves and push it i mean really
push it definitely can't wait i'll see
you first thing in the morning
absolutely thank you good night
i'm glad that kitchen's gonna be shown
what to do and how to do it properly
because this is it it's not only my
kitchen's last chance it's my
restaurant's last chance
good morning good morning wow come in
how are we
good
the chef that i brought in james has
been here since six o'clock this morning
supervising working these ass off with
your team
getting ready for this menu today your
menu will be in keeping with your
beautiful restaurant and your great
service first up
the appetizers come down
now these are appetizers squeezing on
the eye fun goat cheese truffle dip
honey spiced chicken wings meatball
sliders delicious wow now we can have a
real party in our mouth abby
can't wait
okay onto the entrees the main events
seared lamb chopped classic lobster mac
and cheese bacon wrapped angus meatloaf
thank you i want you to get familiar
with the new menu yes get up to speed
with those dishes have a little
this is awesome
that's money the new menu is
beyond belief kind of surprised that it
came out of my kitchen
oh my god that is so good
bacon wrapped meatloaf isn't that
awesome
oh my god that's
unbelievable
i had no idea that it could get this
good oh my god that's amazing i've been
for years describing this restaurant as
creative comfort food i had no clue this
is creative comfort food
oh my god
[Music]
i've never seen abby this emotional like
she does have a heart in theirs she does
have a soul
it's amazing
there is a god
now we just gotta make it work
[Music]
it's relaunch night at down city and
while abby and rico get the front of the
house ready for the most important night
in the restaurant's history we are gonna
rock this town tonight let's go let's go
back in the kitchen and then we're gonna
go here table by table until we have to
do this yes chef james is doing the same
with the kitchen staff every dish
perfect every time folks how are we
doing tonight welcome welcome have you
had a chance to look at all the new and
fun exciting menu items that we have
let's go guys yeah i want to hear you
tonight i want to hit you too yes let's
go only minutes into the service a
locally renowned food blogger has
arrived stacey place ripped apart her
last meal at the restaurant happy you
recognize her yeah you know how
important she is but chef ramsay
convinced her to give it another try she
has 10 000 followers she vlogs tomorrow
we're 10 000 potential customers back up
i've tried everything on this menu today
so if you have any questions you feel
free to ask any favorites
oh yeah definitely the goat cheese
truffle dip really stood out for me well
that sounds really good
jimmy you and i we're going to be
communicating all night i need the 37 17
and 35. all right
right now in the window i need that fish
and chip i need that slider fire's up
chef a reinvigorated jimmy has the
kitchen moving in the right direction
calamari sliders jimmy kimmy going for
salad on the fly and the new menu is
being embraced by the customers
but just when it appears as though it's
going to be smooth sailing i need a
chowder a calamari a slider jimmy did
you call the calamari for table 30. i
just did abby and jimmy listen to me are
having a communication breakdown and i
need four suits and one chowder up in
the line please that's incorrect uh-oh
here we go again a repeat of last night
the kitchen's going down
we're [ __ ] jimmy focus on 37. yeah
this is the golden ticket
this is it all right lead ticket i need
his truck full dip trouble did take six
minutes yes yes sir i get it in the oven
jimmy look at me we're falling behind
we've got to work together
come on guys there's nothing coming out
please let's get this food out give me
your time handle truffle dip please
she's not blogging now
what's she doing she's definitely
vlogging she's vlogging live from the
table we've got bloggers live from their
table guys i need a trouble dip up on
the line right now urgently please i was
horrified we were sleeping like the
night before they're vlogging as we
speak i wanted to like just scream
come on guys i need some food on the
line there's nothing hitting the window
come on guys i need to see some food up
on this line it's taking too long
literally my kitchen going down in
flames
listen jimmy one minute abigail and
there was literally nothing i could do
about it
jimmy i need a truffle dip come on guys
it's 45 minutes into dinner service
let's get this food out we've got
bloggers live from their table guys and
an influential food blogger who can
greatly affect the future of down city i
need a double dip up on the line right
now still has not received her
appetizers abby two seconds quickly
let's take over take over let's go happy
she just tweeted waiting for appetizers
getting hungry okay this is not [ __ ]
now menu's there chefs are there i need
you there control it yeah i know what
you're capable of yes and it's been
tough for the last couple of days
granted however you've got to find your
voice okay come on all right okay please
please it's definitely time to step it
up we want everything to go right with
that table and we're gonna get the job
done listen jimmy they're already
vlogging that they're waiting too long
for food let's get this food out all
right how long on a solo truffle dip
urgently please trouble dip behind you
thank you trouble in the sally
season's there with that caesar i need
sliders and a truffle deck come on
[Music]
amazing yes come on keep it going yes
entrees make sure
they come together okay fire that table
please yeah jimmy what's 37 did you fire
i did fire him
so we got everything this is a really
good season
with abby focused on the task at hand
let's get loud back there and jimmy in
full control of his kitchen you guys can
fire that fish and chip quality entrees
are quickly heading out to the dining
room
lamb chops salmon ribs fillets
food looks amazing
the food looks outstanding absolutely
amazing
it appears as though blogger stacy place
has reached her verdict
and she's not the only one
do you like that and those chips aren't
they delicious a lot better than last
night right yeah definitely how was
everything delicious
right there everything was great great
thank you so much for coming in and
we're going to see you again i was
living an absolute kitchen nightmare and
my dream just came true i'm an absolute
shock like this is the restaurant i've
always wanted those the last few
desserts
jimmy
it's awesome thank you
it's a new dell city i'm just absolutely
loving it
right
last night
i said down city
needed to make a comeback tonight we did
just that
well done
each and every one of you
pulled off
a great service
customers
loved the food
abby
how do you feel babe i feel beyond
belief fantastic
looking back at it now i was so
unprofessional
[ __ ] out of my restaurant
the new abbey is professional i just
want to continue learning
it's just made me such a better leader
come on in give me a hug
you're not going to ask me i'm going to
ask you that's right i gordon ramsay are
asking you for a hug come here
huh
i absolutely love chef ramsay and uh i'm
gonna miss him when he goes thank you
very much russell this restaurant is
getting back on the map that it hasn't
been on in a while and i know it's only
gonna get better
good night
without question the biggest
transformation this week is abby which i
never expected as abby goes so goes down
city if she can keep her call this
restaurant gonna be a huge success
wow party in my mouth please
[ __ ]
[Music]
after chef ramsay left chef james stayed
on and continued to train the cooks he
gets prepped and put away allowing jimmy
the chance to thrive all right the
meatloaf's being plated that sells the
lead and abby rewarded him with a
promotion i wanted to introduce to all
of you our head chef james berman
eager to spread the word about their
upgraded restaurant
abby and rico hit the town this is a
crispy pork belly in a lettuce cup doing
some grassroots marketing by giving out
samples of their new menu it's right
down the street it's walking distance
chef ramsay saved my restaurant he
really did but i've got to continue it i
promise him that the next time he comes
back the food will be a 10.
[Music]
you